hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
hearts of Westminster well it all got
very personal in prime minister's
questions today Kirsten and Rishi sunak
clashed over whether private school
should have charitable status the Prime
Minister who went to the prestigious and
expensive Winchester college so the
leader of the opposition was attacking
the aspiration of people like his
parents meanwhile there's no sign of the
winter of discontent thawing with 10 000
ambulance workers going on strike so
plenty for us to get stuck into as we
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes
he's attacking people like my parents Mr
Speaker this is the country that
believes in Opportunity not resentment
he
'd just stand that and that's why he's
not fit to lead
well that was the PM pretty annoyed
about what he says as labor playing the
man and not the ball over private
schools with the kistama it's fair game
every week he hands out cash to those
that don't need it
[Applause]
and on every week he gets weaker
well I wonder what voters will make of
the debate about private education and
if we're the prime minister went to
school matters we are going to be
finding out who better to ask her than
the most important people you at home
we'll see what our viewers panel make of
that pmqs you can see them there
everyone hello we'll talk to you a bit
later on in the program we'll also have
some top guests for you including the
tech and digital economy Minister Paul
Scully Labor's Shadow work and pension
secretary Jonathan Ashworth and we'll be
talking to the chair of the women and
equalities committee Caroline notes lots
to talk to her about and much more
besides on the take
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
like after all the chaos of the last few
months we were onto much more
traditional ground at pmqs today Labor
attacking the privilege of private
schools and a conservative PM defending
aspiration is politics back to normal
well maybe that's a bit far so let's
crack on shall we we are going to start
with the best bits of the week so far
China's ambassador to the UK has been
summoned to the foreign office over the
arrest an alleged beating of a BBC
journalist who was covering the covert
protests in Shanghai
[Applause]
white pieces of paper that's becoming a
real symbol of the process to
hard to express just how incredibly
unusual these scenes are in China the
so-called Golden Era is over we
recognize China poses a systemic
challenge to our values and interests
now the health secretary says that the
possibility of diphtheria spreading in
the community is very low following the
death of a man who'd been at the manston
processing center in Kent so from today
no one presenting with symptoms will
progress into the Asylum accommodation
system why is the Home Secretary not
here this this is supposed to be her top
priority we now start with questions as
prime minister if he thinks the
rotary is tax breaks breaks live at
school
and that summed up down to state school
that's laughable Mr Speaker whenever he
attacks me about where I went to school
he is attacking the hard-working
aspiration of millions of people in this
country
[Applause]
I said at the beginning tonight that it
feels a little bit like we're edging
back to Politics as Usual and actually
watching at that montage by our producer
Jared it does feel like we're actually
getting back to talking about some of
those bread and butter issues
immigration education Foreign Affairs
well a little earlier I spoke to Paul
Scully about some of those things he's a
minister at the department for digital
culture media and Sport
today more than 10 000 ambulance workers
have voted to go on strike they feel
that a four percent pay award is just
simply not keeping up with inflation
it's a real terms can't do you have
sympathy with them well clearly we want
to make sure that um all workers
especially for urban public sector
workers are doing really important work
like our ambulance workers get get a
fair pay
um uh settlement and that's why we've
um accepted the pay review uh work
that's been done by the pay review body
who've looked at all of the different
factors and it is a challenge clearly
it's a challenge because I can
understand why people can see their
prices going up and want uh their wages
to match we see people in the private
sector the equally is challenged and
their prices their wages aren't going up
but we've got to be realistic we've got
to make sure that first of all we can
afford it in terms of the public sector
the money that's coming out the treasury
I think if you looked at the nurses
settlement for example it equates to
something like nine billion pounds on
the NHS budget that's got to come from
somewhere but also you risk stoking
inflation as well at the same time
though you know ambulance workers that's
an acutely stressful job I mean I can
imagine how how difficult it is we've
seen the record waiting times we've seen
the stories about people you've been
treated in ambulances outside hospitals
because they can't get a bed it's not
too much to ask that their pay package
shouldn't be shrinking at this time no
these are I say these are difficult
times it's a real you know especially
for ambulance workers because of those
extra pressures that are on them at the
moment in the NHS and of course at this
time of year anyway regardless of
picking up still from from covid but no
I come back to the point and it is
difficult to
to think through when you are worrying
about paying your bills and worrying
about uh the the cost of living and what
you're seeing in all the newspapers and
of course all the broadcast and
everything like that professors from
everywhere across the world but the
problem is if you start stoking
inflation then these pressures will last
longer inflation is supposed to be a
global challenge that's what you guys
keep telling us it's all about how much
nurses get paid no it is because well
look if you think about the bank of
England the bank of England look has one
lever to tackle inflation interest rates
so it puts interest rates up and down
and so basically if inflation continues
because there is more money coming into
the economy then the bank has one labor
to pull interest rates so actually by
giving them more money now what you're
finding is their mortgage rates will
carry on going up later and so it's
trying to get it is a real fine balance
it's unaffordable that's what you're
trying to say you know effectively
overall we've got to make something that
that is Affordable is proportionate but
is at least as Fair as possible you know
you've just been talking about the
financial pressures about what
affordable what isn't is it affordable
for the private school should continue
to be accepted from va2
look I think this is a really uh this is
a debate that I can understand the
politics around it you know you saw
kirst armor talking today about
Winchester
um frankly if you take vat off private
schools now without the thought about
how you how you Model Behavior change
you'll see a load of schools load of
schools close you'll see people taking
their children out out of Independent
Schools it won't be Winchester Harrow
eating those kind of big Elite schools
that everybody always thinks about it'll
be the middle of the road schools
especially prep schools where and those
those people have to go into State
education so what you're doing now where
is kirst armor again understandably for
political reasons says well we're
subsidizing them by 20 well guess what
you'll be subsidizing by 100 if they
actually move into the states I'll be
honest I I am struggling to understand
this I've been fully right because if
you're a state school you have to act
within your budget all the time
inflation has meant sudden changes to
State School budgets as well right and
so what do they do they have 30 pupils
in the class they have to ask teaching
assistants they have to scrap music
lessons surely the same would happen for
private schools you would just cut your
cloth you'd make budget savings just
like in the states so what you have
that's why I was talking about those
middle type schools actually because
what you already have in the independent
sector in parts of the independent
sector when you get outside Elite
Schools they're already Under Pressure a
lot of businesses
I wonder what what you're finding is
that a lot of prep schools for example
they go up to 13. there is no there is a
dwindling market for schools in this
country that go up to 13 and so they're
all starting to Pivot and change and
what you're finding at some schools are
failing some schools are closing already
some schools are being taken over
um but I come back to the point that if
you've got a school with small
relatively small role numbers and then
they start going back into the state
system not only do those businesses fail
because they are as I say businesses
just slash Charities however we want to
turn them then you have the uh
um state school you're adding pressure
into the state schools system they want
to then they will need to build schools
where are they going to find the land to
build the schools it will be the old
Independent School sites that have just
closed down so you effectively
cross-funding in that way so you're not
going to get a major economic benefit I
just want to have a look um at a graph
that I think shows some of the
difference in per-pupil funding so
whether it's fees charged private
schools or if it is the things that they
get from the government from the state
sector now this is the change in school
funding uh per pupil you can see the red
line of course the state schools the
blue line is private schools and
according to the ifs 6 500 pounds more
is spent per pupil in the private sector
than the state sector are you really
saying funding can't be you know
squeezed in the private sector if you
look at this graph what I'm saying what
I'm saying is that the Zone intended
consequences I'm just I'm not saying
that you can't make any changes because
bearing in mind the the vat changes that
you're talking about my understanding
and it may go this way but I think that
although they get the 20 percent vat
they're not allowed to claim back so
actually if they if you remove that from
them and they go they've become a Pure
business rather than the charity they
will be able to claim their their vat
back so again you're not going to get
the quite that Gap closed that you think
you're going to get it's all about
unintended consequences for me
I was hoping you might be able to clear
something up for you on onshore winds
but be completely honest I'm finding
quite hard to keep up with what the
government position is we know of course
British seen like wanted to continue
with the effect of ban on new onshore uh
wind he's now of course coming to
pressure from Rebels including Boris
Johnson and Liz truss so what is the
current position then well I'm in the
current position is is a is aware the
you know the fact that there is you have
to have Community buy and you have
Community consent there is there's there
has been no change but clearly this
amendment's coming in there's a lot of
people that have some people have an
overarching view that they want to see
more onshore wind but there are a number
of people that have signed that
amendment that have constituency issues
in particular and you know we're in the
middle of a process as ever uh where
whereas um you know the government will
be listening and we'll be talking to
those people to see where we can land it
what's your own view because you know
Grant shops has sat here saying it's a
nice or then you get other concert of
MPS you say look this is a really cheap
way of getting green energy what's your
view will it I can see both sides
because there's there's not a lot called
Financial wind turbines in cycling team
so I've not had that direct
responsibility in my part of Southwest
London as a constituency MP to be fair
but if you look at and I can understand
the appeal but I can also understand
that the difficulty of living with one
of those or the prospect of having an
onshore wind turbine it's important
however we do it that we take people
with us it's you know we're doing great
things with offshore wind
um I actually gave planning permission
one of the last things I did as business
Minister for size of our city and so I
noticed that the government has uh has
given the go ahead for that it's getting
the mix right that's that's the key
thing and now there's another story that
I wanted to ask you about well I've got
you um Prince William's godmother uh
resigned after asking negozi philania
where she really came from at a
reception at Buckingham Palace and when
Miss Fellaini said that she was British
lady Susan Hussey said I can see I'm
going to have a challenge getting you to
say where you're from
she has um it stood aside from her job
as a result of that is an example of
racism
I think there's a lot of casual racism I
say that someone is half Burmese that uh
you know there's often this kind of idea
that uh people say yeah but where are
you really from
um you know that's uh takes a bit of
unfortunately we're still having to
educate people so you think it is an
example of casual risk I think you know
I think there is this casual sort of a
approach sometimes which you have to be
careful because uh you know I'm all for
free speech but um but why on Earth
would you want to offend someone by that
way and you can understand why she's
offended buyer yeah yeah that makes a
lot of sense definitely yeah I mean look
I mean as I say you know when I was
growing up I was a you know I don't
consider myself particularly dark but I
had a slightly dark skin than than some
of my friends and they knew my Burmese
background and uh you know there's a lot
of casual racism in that you see was
that a school that you yeah yeah uh and
then it's and and then some of that
stuff and stuff tends to get written
offers uh oh but it's just banter and
then
um you know this instance it's the first
time I've I've I've heard about this
this um example that you that you put in
front of me but as I say from everything
you just said it just sounds like a it
can easily be swept away as just a
casual conversation but I was just
interested not really appropriate tell
me to you know go away if you want but
if you wanted to talk a bit about what
happened at school then you know oh no
but it's just you know for me it was
name pointing it was it was children
really I think exploring their
boundaries I'm not I didn't have a bad
time no no quacky there's no way I would
I would ever describe myself as having a
uh you know discriminatory childhood but
it was just it was name-calling it was
it was sort of banter when actually if I
wanted to kick back and I did every now
and again people realized so I was I'm
very lucky in that regard but you can
you can as you say from your own
experiences but also just looking at you
know the world around you you can
understand how someone would react to
what as you said it's casual risk yeah
because look I think I'm really proud of
my Burmese Heritage which is why I do
talk about it a lot and I and I'm sure
um yeah this lady that is proud of hers
um and it's important that uh
you don't counter that the the uh but
but on the other hand and I'm glad
people are interested in people's
Heritage there's Ways and Means and
that's not what she was saying yeah yeah
exactly there's Ways and Means about
about going about inquiring shall we say
thank you very much for being on the
show it's been really interesting to
talk to you today pleasure
Paul Scully well let's get Labor's take
on some of that now uh shall we because
we're joined by the shadow work and
pension secretary Jonathan Ashworth
who's in the studio for us today and
thanks for coming on the program
pleasure um I just want to start with
what Paul Scully was saying there I
thought he spoke quite powerfully
actually about the comments uh that were
made by Prince William's Grandma
godmother he said that it was an example
of casual racism do you think it was
yeah I think it is and they're just
patri Paul I thought he spoke very
bravely about his own personal
experiences there and that can be very
difficult to speak about one's personal
experiences I think it is an example of
casual racism and I think as I
understand I just only saw the news
breaking tonight uh as I understand it
palaces have you know moved this
individual on quite rightly sir
there is a lot of casual racism in
society and we always have to stand firm
against it I was struck by that this
week because we have the census results
out this week and I represent Leicester
we're very proud of our diversity in
Leicester and Leicester is a a city with
a majority ethnic population and I was
very struck by the tone of some of the
language from some prominent people
actually around
which are making comments about cities
like Leicester and Birmingham in
response to this census state are there
any comments that you were particularly
important I mean I think there were I
mean I don't want to name individuals
because it's been videos but I mean it's
just the way in which there were sort of
suggestions I thought particularly on
social media that somehow that Leicester
was
on Christian or on elsewhere or
something like that I think things like
that and
um
I'm immensely proud of the rich
diversity of a city like Leicester I
think it and I think it strengthens us
as a city where a dynamic city today
because of our diversity I imagine that
the same would be the case in Birmingham
and other parts of the country and I
think we should always celebrate that
diversity but it is a it was a sad
reminder that there is still casual
racism out there and we have to stand
firm against it yeah exactly I think it
feels like it's sort of two kind of
examples of that I guess some would say
that
is there a blurring sometimes of the
Casual relations that you're talking
about and other concerns about
immigration
look at
it you know I mean people will have
always have legitimate concerns about
immigration because they'll always have
legitimate concerns about
you know economic circumstances and
whether whether the economy is growing
sufficiently in order to ensure good
decent good decent well-paying jobs for
everybody so it's understandable that
people will have concerns about
immigration and that's why you've got to
have an immigration system which
responds to your economic needs which is
why we've said we need a points-based
system we know that there are gaps in
the labor market but what I would also
say and I'll say a little bit about this
earlier this week actually when you've
got increasing numbers of people leaving
the labor market employment is lower
today than it was pre-pandemic there's
more more over 50s leaving the labor
market there's actually more and more
people forced out of work for reasons of
ill health two and a half million the
highest for 20 years it's costing us 8
billion extra a year a year we actually
need schemes initiative measures to
support people to return to work and one
of my big preoccupations is to get
Britain back to work and put in place
the measures to help people so I'm I was
saying let's devolve more employment
support to local area is because they
know that they they know what's needed
in their area let's better link up the
Employments this the employment support
system with with the NHS let's reform
our job centers because they're not
working as the valued Public Service in
every community that they should do to
get the over 50s back to work to give
support for those who are out of work
for reasons of sickness when they need
it so there's big reforms that we've
been putting forward this week to
improve our economy
um I was also talking to Mr Scully about
strikes because of course we have 10 000
ambulance workers now um obviously a
very stressful very high pressure Job
saying that they are going to strike
because they want their pay to reflect
inflation would you like to see
inflation matching pay rises in the
public sector well I mean as you know I
led on health for labor party for what
felt like 100 years
um so I understand that NHS staff
whether it's paramedics or nurses or
Health Care assistants are under the
most considerable strain and have been
asked to do more and more with less than
less over many years now for 12 years
and they face very tight pay packets
wage squeezes for many years I think the
trade unions who represent the health
workers will need to negotiate and
that's why it's incumbent upon the
health secretary not just to say on my
door is open but to actually say right
let's get around the table let's see if
we can hammer out a deal because it's
not just about pay it's also about rotor
gaps it's also about safe Staffing my
question was about payday right yeah
your question was do you think that
workers in the NHS should get inflation
matching payments well they should get a
they should get a fair pay settlement
what does that mean I mean everyone
would say they should get off there but
what is the fact but let me matching
inflation but let me give you an example
here the government will have modeling
of what is Affordable now the government
Minister say no it's not affordable it's
not affordable but they've also they're
not giving you the full picture because
they're not taking into account how many
NHS staff are claiming Universal Credit
to top up their wages low paid NHS staff
will be getting Universal Credit so even
though on the one hand the government
will be saying we can't give of your pay
rise but on the other hand they're just
topping up their wages with Universal
Credit the taxpayer is still paying so I
it's not a cop-out the government will
have access to all that model okay it's
not a cop-out but I am really unclear
and I think most people would be quite
unclear listening because because I you
know in a negotiation it's not it's not
helpful for a politician who hasn't got
access to all that Dynamic model it's
just pick a number out of thin air and
say it should be X or it should be y the
government know how many how much how
many what is Affordable they'll also
know what their modeling is for what
they will get back in tax because
obviously nurses and paramedics will be
paying National Insurance and income tax
and they'll also have a modeling for how
many are claiming Universal Credit all
those factors need to be taken into
account one thing that would help make
things more affordable is raising the
state pension age a male strategy or
opposite number at the department for
which work and pension said there's a
review Interstate retirement age
considering the cost of taxpayers and
intergenerational fairness as well as
life expectancy what's your view on
raising the retirement age well we
always have reviews every so often
they're periodic and that's always been
the case throughout throughout the
throughout the recent history of the
state of pension age and when these
periodic reviews have looked at the
evidence and and they are usually
independent reviews when they've made
independent recommendations we have gone
along with that but there has to be an
import the review has to be allowed to
take place and politicians shouldn't
preempt it it's also now got to take
into account things like life expectancy
because the Assumption has been that
life expectancy would improve and indeed
life expectancy has improved since since
the war but life expectancy has begun to
stall but that's why we have an
independent review process and we'll see
what that independent review process
reports upon we shouldn't be
politicizing that independent review
process because the public finances are
in such a mess because of 12 Years of
the of lackluster growth and the you
know the recent disastrous budget about
two months ago now which
the economy it has to be a proper
process okay thank you very much for
being on the program because talk good
to have you in the studio
on the street it's always always a treat
thank you
well a little later on the program we're
going to be speaking to the chair of the
women and equalities committee Caroline
notes but first uh let's try and work
out what we've learned so far shall we
can talk to our Deputy at political
editor uh Sam coats uh good to have you
with us what stood out actually from the
interview so far well I think first of
all I want to pay tribute to Jonathan
Ashworth he's uh just getting up from
his seat behind me for talking down the
clock on the multiple occasions that you
asked him whether or not to give a
public SEC that labor would give a
public access I can see him just
laughing and eyeballing Sam he's leaving
the studio it was a tremendous effort
but the truth is that essentially the
labor party are never going to say at
the moment they've decided they are
never going to say yes we will give
inflation matching pay Rises to public
sector pay and there's a very clear
reason for that because they think that
they want to prove to the public that
they can be safe stewards of the public
finances and that the public would judge
that that wasn't something necessarily
10 11 12 uh 17 in some cases uh that uh
it is Affordable when that runs ahead of
private sector pay more over though the
thing that really struck me was
listening to Paul Scully the
conservative Minister's interview with
you just how much of that was
essentially a discussion on opposition
territory whether it was the opposition
labor party claims about private school
whether it was internal opposition about
about wind farms Richie seen that needs
to get back on the front foot he's not
that long in the job private school
debate in particular have to say strikes
me as I mean this is such fertile ground
for labor right it just feels like this
is exactly the kind of place you can see
where she's sitting there at Prime
Minister's questions almost walking into
the Trap Rishi sunak has a view that he
is on the side of right for his voters
and he is unashamed of the position that
he took Sky revealed earlier this year
he is a personal donor to Winchester
College thousands of pounds of his own
money goes to subsidize uh low-income
students who who end up there he
believes in this the polling suggests
that labor actually are onto something
while pushing this and campaigns like
the one in the Daily Mail don't
necessarily really achieve the ends I
think that they might appear to try and
I'd be really interested actually to get
the views of the viewers panel on
private schools just to see what they
make of it all
um
just quickly as well Sam you know we're
talking there about
um Jonathan Reynolds side stuff in the
question is that good tactics for an
opposition that are so far ahead in the
polls I don't think what Jonathan
Ashworth was saying was memorable that's
the point they don't want you to really
think about what they're saying about
public sector pay it's essentially the
same as the conservatives about
migration they're aping the language of
the conservatives on issues where the
main parties say similar things the
media the public don't find division and
therefore they often gloss over so
actually I think it can work as a tactic
okay always good to talk we'll talk a
bit later to Sam on the program later
because he has a swing on limiter but
he's going to preview it could all go
disastrously wrong so it's definitely
worth sticking around to find out I'm
sure it won't sound um we're joined now
by the conservative MP and chair of the
women and a qualities committee Caroline
notes lovely to have you on the program
hello
um there's so much that we could talk
about but it feels like we should start
with the conference that was on this
week the International Conference full
of lots of really inspirational speakers
about violence against women and girls
in conflict and that's been a lot to
talk about wartime rape in particular
and you know how much of an issue is it
and do you think things are getting
better
oh no I don't think things are getting
better and I really wish they were I
think the steps that we've seen from 50
countries coming together at the
beginning of this week with the UK
leading the way on the Declaration I
think that's progress but what we really
need to see is a cultural approach where
we would all recognize that rape sexual
assault violence against women and girls
as part of conflict is absolutely
abhorrent what we also need to make sure
is that
Russian soldiers for example in Ukraine
are respecting that but across the whole
globe and I think back to when William
Hague was foreign secretary and really
was leading the way on discussing rape
as a weapon of war and it just feels
like globally we've made too little
progress so I really welcome the money
that's going to go in we've seen I think
12 and a half million pounds committed
by the UK government 10 million dollars
from the U.S but we need to have a
cultural approach to supporting
survivors Justice uh measures making
sure that evidence is collected both
effectively and ethically and I've seen
all that in the Declaration this week
but I think we still got a long way to
go yeah um Angela and jolly um described
this week the lack of action by
governments to support survivors is
deeply painful and frustrating I mean we
would all agree with these assessments
but I guess just listen to you talking
about you know the actions of individual
Russian soldiers for example it's so
difficult isn't it to do anything about
what is effectively actions of
individuals
well there is some very serious
allegations about whether in Ukraine
rape is used being used as a systematic
weapon of War so actually there I think
there has to be a the collection of
evidence they have to be brought to
trial we need to see international
criminal courts convened to deal with
that
um but you know Russia's turning itself
into a real Pariah state from which you
have to question whether there's any
route back and what do you think that
means in in reality
what I think in reality it means yet
more probably Decades of sanctions it
means more action by the West against
Russia I think uh inevitably we need to
be making sure that Ukraine has the
resources it needs we've done some great
work over the last uh
10 months uh trying to support Ukraine
making sure that troops have the
training that they need but it's um it's
just such a horrendous situation and
there's so much that I want to talk to
you about
um including what your committee is
looking into
um but there's been a lot of debate
recently about the online harms bill
um which is all about safety online
effectively and something that you know
women and girls feel very strongly about
and it can feel like a place where
there's an awful lot of misogyny if you
take misogyny intervene hatred of women
um do you think that there is a risk the
online harms well it's been watered down
or are you more in the camp that says
look there is a balance to be struck
between harm online and freedom of
speech
well look I want to see online harms
legislation that's going to be effective
I want to see something that is going to
protect children that's an absolute must
as far as I'm concerned I think there
are some good measures in it around
coercive control making that a priority
offense around uh sharing of intimate
images deep fakes I've been really
pleased cyber flashing we're really
pleased to see the engagement that
Michelle Donald's had on that I think
with legislation like this we all want a
bit more don't we and there is I think
the more important balance to be struck
is between making sure that the
regulator is effective making sure that
there are enforcement powers that are
actually going to put the onus on the
social media Giants to make sure that
children are off their platform
um and I I think it's really difficult I
think we have to be realistic about this
that as soon as we legislate there will
be some geek somewhere in the world will
be looking for routes around whatever
legislation's put in place
um you've also been looking at sexism
and football in your committee it feels
something that we should be talking
about right now with the World Cup what
have you been looking at oh look we had
some
um really startling evidence I think it
was a fortnight ago from Fern wheeling
and Susie rack he was a very prominent
Sports journalist talking about the uh
the blatant misogyny that they'd faced
uh the contrast between comments that
they would make uh when reporting on
matches and a male commentator would
make exactly the same comment and get no
abuse I think Susie rack gave us a a
beautiful demonstration of some of the
abuse that she's faced you know and some
of those typical sexist tropes of get
back to the kitchen love but actually
far more Insidious vile uh threats and
commentary against them and I I think
we've got some brilliant examples
haven't we the England women's team
winning the Euros Jill Scott winning uh
I'm a celebrity and these are women who
are real Trailblazers and have set the
standard I think one of the really
fascinating things was the cultural
differences between the man's game and
the women's game I went to the
quarterfinal where England beat Spain
and it there was a fantastic family
atmosphere contrast that with Fern
Whelan saying to us that until
facilities and attitudes improve she
doesn't take us onto football matches
anymore that is quite depressing
actually isn't it I mean some people are
listening you know will have heard the
you know the very very serious stuff
that we spoke about at the beginning
they'll then they'll be listening to you
know this I'll talk about women in
football we'll be like look it doesn't
really matter it's a big deal you know
is it a big deal yeah it is a big deal
because it's about the culture it's
about misogyny it's about the way uh
women
should be respected and to be quite
Frank aren't and it's about some of the
some of the issues that we've been
talking about on the committee over the
last couple of years which are very much
around the Pyramid of offending the the
cultural norms and I hate to say that
the cultural norms that make it okay to
abuse women online and at what point
does your online Predator turn into a
predator in real life and I think with
the committee's working with some
experts to understand that pyramid of
offending and to to understand the
crossover between the virtual world and
the real world and it's all part of how
can we do better how can we make sure
that we uh that we address the root
causes of male violence against women
just finally I'm interested to get your
view quickly on how much you see that's
getting on one concept of MP I spoke to
recently said that you had a zero
percent chance of winning the next
election now he put it at one in five
just share that analysis no I think it's
a lot better than that I'm really
pleased that we have Russia's prime
minister I supported him back in the
summer and I think that he's
doing okay
um it's a long way to go to the next
general election I think I want to see
us come up with some offers particularly
for female voters I want to see us get
the economy back on track I think that's
really important what kind of things for
female voters what okay so I think and
Rishi spoke about this in the summer
we've got to make women feel safe and
we've just been talking about that I
also want to see more action around the
Women's Health strategy to see some real
uh some real effort put into that so
some of the uh and I I hesitate to say
some of the Forgotten conditions you
know the massive weights that we have in
Gynecology at the moment and I want to
make sure that we we come up with some
some good work around Chancellor we know
that the pandemic clobbered the economic
well-being of women and I would love to
see us prioritize how we are focusing on
getting women into better jobs so I
think I'm right and saying that women
are more likely to vote for labor the
men right they are at the moment we have
to change that yeah okay thank you very
much indeed Caroline makes uh there
you are watching the take we're live in
Westminster for you this evening up next
so we're going to take a closer look at
premises questions and also hear from
our viewers panel see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
parts of the take when we take a closer
look at Prime Minister's questions now
the major Party leaders had some pretty
heated exchanges today over private
schools and accused each other at being
weak well here's what our political
correspondent Joe Pike made it all in
pmq's unwrapped
labor seems to have resurrected its
pre-1997 twin track approach to
formulating policy firstly shutting down
historically tricky areas for the party
immigration defense bits of Economic
Policy by making sure there is very
little difference between them and the
conservatives and then at the same time
honing in on key issues where there is a
clear contrast like getting rid of tax
breaks on private schools and when Zakir
starmer raised this today he made
reference to Rishi sunak's own Elite
Education
Winchester college has a Rowing Club a
Rifle Club an extensive art collection
they charge over 45
000 pounds a year in fees why did he
hand them nearly six million pounds of
taxpayers money this year in what is
leveling up secretary calls egregious
State support now that was a nod to
Michael goves back into this very policy
just five years ago if he thinks the
route to better education in this
country is tax breaks for private
schools in the hope they might hand that
sum that down to state school that's
laughable
trickle-down education is nonsense
some conservatives call Labor's policy
class war and the PM argued it's an
attack on aspiration
because we've recently now billions more
funding
we're helping millions of the most
disadvantaged children catch up with
their lost learning whenever he attacks
me about where I went to school he is
attacking the hard-working aspiration of
millions of people in this country
he's attacking people like my parents Mr
Speaker this is a country that believes
in Opportunity not resentment
I thought it was notable that the PM
didn't make the argument that if the tax
breaks end and private schools closed
then the state and taxpayers will likely
have to Fork out Russia sunak did
however raise Labor's internal divisions
on strikes and picket lines kistama
tried to exploit Tory split on house
building and we witnessed both leaders
calling each other weak
he's too weak to stop dozens of his own
MPS joining the picket lines
every week he gets pushed around and
every week he gets weaker elsewhere the
smps in Blackfoot attacked both the
government and the opposition and that's
an even worse site watching the leader
of the labor party desperately trying to
out-brexit the prime minister
[Applause]
and there was clear frustration from the
PM's own side on immigration the number
of people crossing the channel is a
National Emergency the number of
migrants in hotels is a National
Emergency when will my right honorable
friend government bring forward any
emergency legislation that's needed to
deport those migrants who came across
the channel illegally well five weeks
into this new pmq's pairing Kia St Arma
seems desperate to paint Rishi sunac as
a week he's got a message and he's going
to repeat it the danger for the PM
though is the voters think that barb is
believable it could soon stick
Jay Park there taking us through today's
prime minister's questions so that was
the commons this afternoon the key thing
of course is what do people watching at
home make of it all we can talk now to
our viewers uh panel hello everybody
good to have you uh all with us today
now before we start I just want to do a
quick show of hands because I'm actually
really interested to know your views on
the private school debate raise your
hands if you think that it's right that
private schools have charitable status
so if you think it's right that they
have charitable status put your hand up
now
that's two or five and if you think it's
wrong and that they should be stripped
to private school uh with charitable
status put your hand up
to so quite finely balanced then I'm
really interested to get people's takes
on this and find a bit more about your
views let's start off with Stella at
shall we Stella Finley talking to us
from Newcastle Stella what's your view
on uh private schools and whether or not
they should be paying vat
I think it's a difficult one because I'm
not in favor of giving any financial
advantage to the wealthy of this country
but I'm not sure that cutting tax breaks
to private schools is going to Advantage
the state system
um I think there are a lot of people on
middle income who are struggling to put
their children through private schools
and I think that if we did withdraw the
tax breaks to those schools that the
wealthy would still be able to afford it
but it would be those people on the
middle income who would have to take
their children out of private schools
and probably put them into the state
system and then that puts pressures on
this day system
um so I think what you win on the one
hand you're going to lose on the other
um already fees for private schools in
this country are very high they're quite
high in comparison to other countries of
the European countries so I I'm I come
down on the side of
um keeping the charitable status and
giving the tax breaks to the private
schools interesting uh talking about the
the split as you see it between the
private schools on the upper end and
those are more kind of like middle
ranking uh and all right let's talk to
Mike Monroe now shall we Mike's talking
to us from uh Hampshire what what's your
take on the private school debate
I'm with Michael Gove who wrote an
article some time ago about the using
the word that uh
star may use egregious
I think they're a business and they
should be paying v80 like any other
business rather the parents should be
paying VAT on the fees and the vat
relief that the business gets should not
be any more than a normal business
interesting I put children through
private school
sorry
go on
I put children through private school I
wasn't really aware of the fact that
there was a 20 tax break there
um but if I had have been I'm admit I
then was a middle earner I probably
still would have put them through it and
you know spent less on presents or
something
but I appreciate that a lot of people
wouldn't but that doesn't you know you
you can't get away from it you are
subsidizing private education for people
and I believe it would bring in 1.7
billion pounds that could go straight
into
uh either the nurses pay rise the state
school system whatever interesting so
not against private schools per se but
saying that they should be run as a
business rather than a charity right
let's bring in Ross now shall we Roz uh
who's talking to us from hacksby in York
um what's your take do you think private
schools should be exempt from beauty
no
um they're not Charities they're
businesses and I have
I don't understand why people would want
to send their children for private
schools for any other reason than social
exclusivity really because it's
perfectly possible to succeed in state
schools I did all my children have and I
think what parents are paying for is
social exclusivity and I actually think
well if you want that
you know don't expect us to give you a
tax break for it and I'm not sure that
the social exclusivity is a good thing
at all I think for all children to be in
the state sector mixing with all
children is actually a really good thing
and when you look at the um the culture
and the attitudes of a lot of these
children who are educated privately I
don't think it's good and I don't think
it's in the interest of social cohesion
but to actually give people a tax break
for uh wanting to buy social privilege I
think is entirely wrong and the money
that would then be available in the uh
to the public sector whether we use it
in education or we use it in health is
really significant we're not talking
about small beer here and I'm not going
to cry for anybody who can't afford
private education as a result of losing
their tax break I have no problem with
that whatsoever okay well I saw a couple
of people shaking their heads to some of
what you were saying there uh Ross so
let's go to Hannah next hour way Hannah
Underwood talking to us from Hartford
Hannah I saw a little Shake of your head
at one point what's your view on the
private school debate
it's a difficult one for me because uh
we do send our child to private school
and it's got nothing to do with social
exclusivity at all I'd be quite happy
for my son to go to a state school but
our nearest school is not a good school
and I don't we didn't we chose not to
send our son there and we could have
moved I mean this is the irony about
this whole sort of debate really is that
wealthy parents can move next to good
schools at estate schools and poorer
parents can't do that so quite often
you'll find a school that doesn't do as
well academically in a poorest of area
and then wealthier parents as the same
move towards the good State schools so
there's nothing to do with I want my son
to have the Rough and Tumble but I also
want him to do well academically I
de-sympitize I mean if the money if it
didn't if our school wasn't a charity it
isn't the end of the world and you write
1.8 billion if it helps State schools it
helps some of the poorer children
absolutely I'm all for that um I didn't
have a private school education I went
to a grammar school
um and I went on to University came from
a single parent background so I have not
had a privileged out bringing it's got
nothing to do with class or anything
like that it's simply what is the best
for my child and I can afford to do so
and that's what we you know choose to do
but I think the whole education system
really needs to be looked at and perhaps
more money put into it overall anyway
it's been great to hear everyone's views
on this so it's you know in personal
experiences it really shows I think the
kind of different views on such a
important debate right let's finish up
with Bruce whoops I need to drop my
cards there uh Bruce Tyler East Riding
of Yorkshire you are talking to us from
uh Bruce Bruce where do you fall on this
debate
so um I hope you can hear me my um
connection seems a bit dodgy but um on
the assumption that you can
um we uh my wife and I wanted to send
our children through
um a private system because we went
through the state system ourselves
um and when we went through the State
education system we found the uh
standard of teaching uh unreliable uh we
didn't want to open uh our children to
that particular risk so um we put them
through an independent uh Day School
um and you know with that was quite a
difficult struggle financially to do so
um and we know a number of parents who
were in our peer group at the time
who did find it a real struggle to put
their children through a private
education system now fast forward 10 15
years from where we were I suspect a lot
of parents who were trying to do that
are finding it extremely difficult at
the moment the proportion of their
income that they are spending having to
spend on food and fuel and their
mortgage and other kinds of expenditure
that have gone up with inflation uh
these are all taking bigger chunks out
of their income so I do fear that um an
increase in the price of schooling would
actually be the straw that breaks the
camel's back brilliant and I think we
would see a lot of children coming out
of the um the the private sector and
having to go back into the public sector
we're out of time now but I don't see
that the public sector will be ready for
that it's been really interesting to
have all your views whether it's on the
uh you know the Rights and Wrongs of
private schools education or
specifically whether they should get tax
breaks as well great to talk to you all
as ever you're watching the take we are
live here in uh Westminster up next
we're gonna be rounding up everything we
have just heard and looking at our very
new swingometer
[Music]
sport guys how would happen you get four
different versions but this is where all
of them start
[Music]
cherry pie
[Applause]
and you come out tonight
we've all been in the show since last
June we all joined together yeah yeah
and then Carl did the tour before us
yeah I've been with the production since
2017. okay and you're just extending the
Run yes yeah yeah it's October 1st 2023.
so it's the story of these four iconic
men who uh it's the rise and the fall of
this iconic band who have brought
incredible songs
um and you're gonna leave the theater
singing along doors
Tommy is um I mean he's a wonderful
character to play get to get to do that
every night but he essentially is the
reason it all happens I'm not going to
take anything away
actually it's kind of like it is it's
Tommy's story essentially Frankie sings
all these amazing songs
um but he is the guy that that brought
it all together
um and along the way found himself in
some real sticky situations and the show
touches on all of those things
all the drama that goes with being in a
group and rising to fame so quickly and
you know all the struggles it takes to
get that it's all it's all in this
musical yeah four seasons were the
American version of The Beatles
but then they'd not had a sound like
this before obviously Frankie Valli's
voice was so different to everybody
else's
so yeah I mean obviously there's not a
bad song that they've written Nick
Massey yeah he what a great guy he was
he uh he basically made all the
harmonies any Harmony you hear for any
of their songs he just picked him picked
him up on the spot he's got he had such
a good ear for it he uh
gave them their sound essentially he
taught Frankie how to sing there was a
time where where Tommy went to prison so
now I went to prison we all went to
prison for Frankie you know I think it
is a story of him starting as the little
man in the group he doesn't really have
much of a voice to then becoming the
huge star that he was and then leading
on his own I mean you lose members of
the group as the show goes on and you do
see that he really is someone who tries
to hold it together for fan uh for
Frankie families everything
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back to the take we've had
lots of takes this evening let's have a
take of sand coats and Sam I'm really
interested in this because it feels like
there's an awful lot of things that
we've been discussing on the program
from strikes to private schools you can
see the Contours or the debate between
Kirsten and Rishi sunak really starting
to come into Focus now and what impact
is it having on the public and on
polling because you've got a new tool to
play with that I have in here which I'm
quite excited about that's right and the
impact on the public is perhaps not as
dramatic as you might expect from a
change of prime minister look here is
the gap between the labor party up here
on 48 in the latest yougov poll and the
conservatives down on 25 he's still a
huge 23 Point Gap Advantage for the
labor party couple of things to work to
note that are going on here uh still
we've got here this policy is the Reform
Party they're the right wing party
eating into the conservatives Nigel
farage possibly coming back with them
then from in the back from the right you
don't have a great deal of buying from
any group beneath 65 years of age above
65 they Trend Tory but below that
they're all voting labor but labor
suffered the worst defeat since 1935 in
the last election I've got to build back
a huge way so we've got a new tool here
which is a swingometer that will tell us
help explain just how difficult kirst
Armor's job is so this is where the
result was at the last election and as
you go up here this would represent
labor doing better and better and better
against the conservatives in this
spring-ometer produced by Patrick
English of yougov and it it would
require an eight percent swing for
kierstama just to get Eden to number 10
with an unstable Coalition 12 swing for
labor to have an overall majority and an
almost 20 spring for there to be a
landslide let's look at where to the
latest yougov poll comes out here
and it's here about 17 so actually
currently a pretty big majority for
labor in the offing but it has to be
said uh there's only been one election
since the second world war really where
there's been more than a swing of five
percent and that was the general
election 1997 where Blair won by a
landslide that uh means that to get just
a majority over majority of one uh labor
care Summers labor needs to do better
than that it's quite interesting isn't
it though because if you're still we're
looking at this you'd be pretty pleased
with where you are right now absolutely
and I think that it's remarkable that
Rishi sunak is having no kind of Bounce
no kind of honeymoon yes he's personally
doing better in some areas like the
economy than Russia's uh than uh
kirstama uh but such a big gap overturn
it looks really hard even maybe two
years out from the election uh great to
talk as always uh Sam thanks so much for
joining us on the take this week we're
here every week 9 p.m on Wednesday
nights on Sky News next up it's Sky News
at 10.
[Music]